-Hi, everybody. I'm Seth Meyers.
As we did last night, I'm going
to turn over the top of our show
to "Late Night" writer
Amber Ruffin.
The crisis we're going through
is at its heart about anger
and frustration
in the Black community
over years of mistreatment
by law enforcement.
So here is Amber
with another story.
-Last night, I told you a story
about an encounter I had
with police.
Now let me tell you
another story.
One time, a few years ago,
I was living in Amsterdam.
And I flew to Chicago
for the weekend
to visit some friends
who live there.
When I got there, my friend Jeff
and I hopped in his car
and headed out to pick up
our friend Krasney,
who just so happened to live
next to the alley
behind the police station.
So, Jeff parks his car
at the gas station
at the end of the alley
so that I can run out,
go pick up Krasney,
and take her back to the car.
I'm freaking thrilled.
I hadn't seen her in years.
So, we were all going to
go have dinner and catch up.
Now, I get out of the car
and go down the alley.
And because Jeff is watching me,
I skip down the alley
to her house to make him laugh,
you know?
But little did I know
skipping down a police-station
alley is a big no-no.
Because I end up
skipping towards a cop car
that's driving at me
down the alley.
The sirens go off.
A cop gets out,
and his gun is drawn.
And he goes, "Put your hands
on the hood of the car!
Put your hands on the hood!"
This man is furious.
I comply,
and his partner pats me down.
Now, this man is livid.
It makes no sense.
His anger level towards me
is insane.
I am a young, adorable, delight
literally skipping
down the street,
and I've infuriated him.
So, this man asked me,
"Where are you coming from?"
And I go, "Amsterdam."
Now, this answer enrages him.
And he goes, "No, where are you
coming from right now?
Where are you coming from?"
And I go, "From the airport.
From a flight. From Amsterdam."
And he goes, "Why in the world
are you running down
this alley?!"
I go, "I'm not running.
I'm skipping.
I'm happy to be back in town.
I'm going to pick up
my friend Krasney
and take her back to Jeff's car,
and we're all going to
go catch up over dinner."
And I remember,
"Oh, thank God. Jeff is here."
I gesture back to Jeff.
Jeff is standing outside of his
car just watching all of this.
And he goes --
So, the cop and I see Jeff.
And thank God Jeff
didn't come running up to us,
because he could have
gotten us both shot.
But the cop sees that Jeff,
a white man, has seen all this,
and he changes his attitude
with the quickness.
He's suddenly professional
instead of antagonistic.
And he tells me
that I was wrong for running.
And it takes everything in me
not to tell him
that if I wanted
to run down the alley,
that would be perfectly legal.
So, instead,
I also gently remind him
that I was not running,
I was skipping.
So, the cop gets in his car,
and he leaves.
And I walk to Krasney's house.
I get her.
We take her back to the car.
Jeff is really bothered
by what happened, but I'm not.
[Bleep] That man could have
shot me in a second.
People who know me would be
running around talking about,
"Attacking an officer
doesn't seem like
something Amber would do,
but the officer said she did,
so that has to be
what happened."
So...
The second I see Krasney,
I feel a lot better.
And we go, and we have
a lot of fun that night.
And if you think about it, it's
kind of my duty to have fun
because at any time, I could
get murdered by the police.
Now, every Black person I know
has stories like that.
[ Sighs ]
It's crazy that people don't
run around telling everyone
these stories all the time.
But there's this unspoken rule
that Black people are
supposed to take it in stride.
Can you imagine having
someone pull a gun on you
and being expected
to take it in stride?
Now imagine a bunch of incidents
like that over one lifetime,
multiply that by
43 million African-Americans,
and that is why things
are like this right now.
That is why people are angry.
And if you're not angry...
why not?
-Thank you, Amber.